to want men to emote like women but he's
not a woman he's a man I can't throw a
good woman straight away it has to be a
long course of time if you don't show
your wife credentials to the man what do
you think he's gonna do the way guys go
on they act like money is nothing to
them I've never relied on a man for
anything in my whole entire life I'll
give you an example how tall was your
last boyfriend
um six one okay what percent of men do
you think are six one
maybe like
30 percent
10 percent
so you had a top did how much money did
he make well you had he had his own
houses and a business he sells cars okay
so roughly well how much do you think he
made
I didn't I she don't know that yeah man
ain't telling you that yeah but he owned
it I know about his business
yeah okay so if he owned a house he
probably made at least like 60 70 I
guess who knows he had a nice range okay
so he's he's probably like I'm guessing
right I don't actually know you guys
would know London prices more than me
but he's probably still top 20 of income
probably because buying a house in Essex
is cheap yeah okay so top 20 so you had
a guy top 10 high top 20 income was he
attractive was he good looking yeah he
was yeah so in women so you know women
we find 80 of men is ugly
so if you find him attractive it means
he's top 20 right you should maybe call
him is he still singing no he's been
trying to holler at me to be honest I
don't have to block him
he's not the one for me what is the one
so it seems like he has a good job
attractive and Tall his person
no no no it's not I'm very smart trust
me like he was wearing a mask when we
first met and then his true colors came
out and I saw it in certain behaviors
that he was portraying what true colors
so like you know he was very aggressive
sometimes and he I felt like his mom
what do you mean aggressive did he hit
you
no no he didn't hit me no okay so he
didn't well he pushed me he shoved me
very hard and it was for a very pathetic
reason and he's a liar do you shove him
at all no just once no I don't like to
be aggressive I don't believe in that
[__] anymore I've grown up you know okay
so he he shoved you one time yeah and it
was very and it was petty and he lied at
the time as well and I knew he was lying
about picking up his kids when he wasn't
go he he changed his story like I'm very
observant picking up his kids so I spent
a couple days with him and he and I was
supposed to say the last day and he and
then he all of a sudden he's got to go
and pick up his kids but you're lying
and so it's like you're making me feel
like you don't want to seem you don't
wanna you don't want me to stay anymore
so and then that happened then we broke
up and now he wants me back I know he
went picking up his kids I know he
wasn't because his story changed he told
me something we planned something from
the get-go so I know so so I didn't you
don't have no physical evidence of that
I do I do I do it's very it's very
technical but it's like you think I'm
crazy if I go into it right now shoving
happen like what what led up to that
because he wanted him to leave okay so
literally
okay okay
why do a lot of women like they accuse a
man of being like the bad guy the guy
that hurts them the guy that beats them
but then the reason they like they made
they caused the reason because if you
physically don't move in certain places
it's the way you speak to someone it's
the way you conduct yourself in that
situation but if you're in this has
happened to me before I bet Esther
you know you know um
here and I asked her to leave and she
didn't like the way I asked her to leave
right and then she starts yelling at me
um and then
um well we didn't have security then but
my security would have just picked her
up and taking her 100. but then it's
like the way you're saying this it's
like
I wouldn't have done that see the thing
I would have done that but when it's an
emotional sexual connection you've got
other feelings like you feel rejection
you feel like you're being violated but
it's kind of different you're kind of so
you're kind of making yourself so
basically like you were kind of
overbearing because he you thought he
did something and you had no proof he
did it no I did because he said one he
changed his story but you've never said
two things that contradicted yourself
ever I I have I just happens when you
talk
it's very easy to say the wrong thing if
you're being cross-examined because you
know what when you say earlier on where
am I not analyzing women and women are
analyzing man he's looking at you like
raw so you're gonna argue against me
picking up my kids
however you know it's not all it is yeah
in his head right hold on I'm telling
you something about my kids and you're
arguing against my kids
to
himself
to privacy
of course absolutely
maybe there is something that he just
didn't want you to know maybe he was
Private with the mud like you know I
mean like baby mama situations can be
tricky like sometimes guys don't want to
get you in on all the drama but it's
like you're going into it in bad face so
you're assuming the worst when maybe it
wasn't the worst but I also feel like
it's just the way you conduct yourself
in a sense in a situation as well it's
like I just feel like couldn't we say
that to you though because it's the way
like you didn't listen when he said
leave so it's kind of like as women like
we kind of have this double standard
where we make him the bad guy when it's
like you kind of started it but then
that's oh yeah I remember now that also
the reason was like I've stayed in the
house by myself before and at this point
he like he didn't want me to stay so
it's like if you love me why can't I
stay here while you go and pick up your
child do what you need to do and I'll
stay here tonight and you come back
because he's because that's entitled
it doesn't say oh yeah like if I if I
owned this apartment if I if I want
anyone to leave at any time I have the
right to do that like that wasn't the
issue I honestly I didn't have an issue
with that it was just the way it
happened and the things that he was
saying and the way he was speaking to me
it was kind of like but this is like a
lot of problems with women in
relationships we want men to emote like
women but he's not a woman he's a man
men don't speak like women do like
they're much more Stern and so a lot of
times like we think something's
aggressive but men are just more
aggressive than women you might want to
call them but we're not aggressive he
seems like a hard man to replace
and you said in the beginning that the
men that like you you don't want so that
means then you want don't want you wow I
haven't met the one I think no but
that's like that's what any girl that's
single it just means the men you want
don't want you and it's not meant to be
the thing is it's actually crazy because
there's no one I actually want
apart from there's okay but okay come on
there's nobody in the world that you
would want I'm attracted to like someone
but he's but he's like a celebrity
figure you're like sex appeal but
there's know when I actually think okay
do you think you're on like the level of
a celebrity yeah
I think I think I obviously
no you're you're pretty I think I'm an
amazing person
celebrities like top 10 20 of beauty
like that yeah but remember I think I'm
beautiful I think I'm beautiful without
the botox without without the money
without all that money to do myself up
so I think I'm great this is like a cope
I see women do like it's like you you
think because they have money they're be
they're beautiful when they got there
money helped but if you look at Margot
Robbie before fame that girl was a 10. I
don't know who that is but then you're
doing selectiveness because there's
enough let go there and the money glows
them up only
I disagree not the girls that get there
for looks alone top 20 of beauty you can
look at exceptions like that like Kylie
Jenner she's not she's not beautiful she
wasn't beautiful before nah she's cute
but yeah I mean she wasn't that
beautiful she gets fixed up she wasn't
but but like I'm just saying in general
guys like can we just talk in general
instead of exceptions most celebrities
are top 20 of Beauty in general
and like we could talk about there's
some exceptions like Kylie Jenner did
her lips whatever but most most people
in Hollywood were the top 20 of beauty
wherever they're from
I still don't agree but yeah okay I feel
you
I don't know maybe you should call him
uh closure but he's not the one for me
he's not my definition of the one
I just feel like there's a different
there's a difference in Behavior and the
way you feel as well I can accept I'm
not a possessive person I can accept I
really like my Independence but I just
know there's a certain way that you will
handle someone in those situations that
just wasn't you know what it is though
you know sorry I just know within myself
sorry your only child no I've got
brother and sister are you the youngest
I'm in the middle oh okay you know so
girl
so growing up did you did your mom have
a partner do you have a stepdaughter no
no yeah yeah like no but not permanently
so what in terms of looking at do you
know how to look after a man because
you're saying certain things that in a
relationship is like
if you saw a relationship with your mom
and dad growing up then there's certain
things you wouldn't do in a relationship
you guys saying to keep the man
listen every man every every man that's
been my boyfriend has returned and they
haven't found better
sorry have you ever been married yeah
you've been you've been proposed to have
been engaged not like on on one knee I
haven't had that experience yet but I've
had similar he bought you around yes
I've had similar but not like that we
was young so I promise me basically kind
of like you know what I mean you promise
okay it is what it's the same thing it's
rare for some amount to do that promise
rings don't care no that's because this
record it does not do you think that
meant get go out and buy promise rings
[Music]
but he doesn't really like you to be
because he's not going to do that to
everyone no no I'm not gonna lie but
okay it's never gonna happen it doesn't
count you need a wedding date yeah it's
a wedding date not not a little ring but
I was young anyway no okay so it wasn't
a real it wasn't a real proposal no no
no no okay so so the whole point is like
you're counting things that don't count
it doesn't count if they don't want to
marry you not feel you well they do the
intention is to you know no like men say
things when they mean it they do it
um like you can't you can't count it
like I know what you mean but you know
[__] happens you know I've had guys say
I want to marry you it doesn't count
unless he goes by the Rings this is we
can't like like I don't know why I was
count things that don't count you know
it don't count it so about you've been
proposed to you a couple times
I don't count like
it later so no one's brought a ring and
said no no no it don't count like it's
like I've had a promise ring but it's a
promise ring a wedding written no no
it's not I don't count that but at the
time we feel like it but did he say it
was a promise ring or did he say it's an
engagement ring no he said it was a
promise ring and then he said he was
trying to he said it doesn't count
that's what I'm saying actually he was
trying to get the the property
it it doesn't count
um okay how so everyone went right how
does a guy identify a good woman yeah
random time okay all right man if you
want to say how do I one are any of you
with a good woman
how do you find a good woman how do I
find one yeah identical one
um I think a good woman I can't I can't
throw a good woman straight away it has
to be a longer coaster time she needs to
be how I want when I won when I need her
to be and I won't get that from the
first look basis you know what I mean so
I think at first
um a good woman to me
is a woman that has
good family values that know how to
be around a family that has a good
relationship with her dad
um submissive
um
caring nurturing
healthy
that's about it all right caring that's
about it from you uh and how do you know
a good one so right now this is what you
have to do you have to see her for three
months yeah ask her to make you a coffee
three month things three months
um this is for the woman you picked to
marry so like okay and you can make
edits so it's okay
um take on a coffee date for first date
okay date as many women as possible tell
the difference make sure she's not on
birth control and figure out what her
relationship's like with her family and
her dad what do you agree with disagree
with them would you like to add
[Music]
um
there's loads I need to add to that man
[Laughter]
um
[Music]
so you got to see her for three months
so you guys for three months yeah yeah I
think three months that's enough you can
marry girl three months no no no you
can't oh okay
you know why you got a lot of women are
chameleon not 100
shape shift how how have you ever dated
a girl for three months and she changes
completely yes yes she treat it like
[Laughter]
I have three kids in it so
I saw the biggest change when the woman
had a child okay so how long
how long before you marry or knock her
up whatever I don't know about Mary Mary
look her up three months is a good time
to determine whether she's being genuine
she's wearing a Moscow yeah so you got
to see her for three months in order to
date yeah so you got to see her for
three months in order to date her like
what's that I mean yeah I don't think
you as he said you can't really
determine anyone as the true person as
they're being genuine as they say they
are for like the first three months
January if you lived with someone that's
different if you move in with something
you can see the truth like a lot quicker
actually can I can I I'm sorry I'm a
little add sometimes when when do you
guys expect to sleep with her
it's not a problem if you sleep with a
woman the first night or you sleep with
a woman two months down the line because
man could move different man can wait
without a woman with her as soon as you
can yeah
because you couldn't you could sleep
with a woman straight away and have a
great connection and a great
relationship with her or you can a woman
can hold out for six months or whatever
and there's man out here that will sit
there for six months out all right how
long is too long I need hands okay how
long is too long no matter how good the
girl is you ain't waiting like this is
really three months is the market okay
okay that's why I want hands for the men
are you waiting one all right wait wait
wait wait
two weeks
three weeks
he's so you're putting in three weeks it
depends on the context I mean has she
made other people wait you don't know
them yeah
I mean like how how old is she like I
mean it's just some kind of born-again
Virgin I don't know I don't know
first date like so you don't know you've
just met her off the street whatever
dating app whatever so you have to
determine all right so three weeks you
can wait you're not you're he's okay
four weeks four weeks too long for
anyone no five weeks okay two months too
long
to sleep with her the two months is the
max all right after that yeah
I get bored easily so after two months I
might two two months yeah I'll go I'll
go with two to three months two to three
months all right so three all right so
you guys two you said I don't know but
the thing is I've done three months when
I was young maybe when I'm older now I
don't I don't know that's why I'm in but
when I had the three months back my
relationship before you meet a nice
woman do you think you're you're looking
for she's the one then yeah but I have
to be convinced yeah yeah
you have to be in her life for that
whole time I understand her how old are
you again I'm 29. okay you're 29. so how
old women do you usually date around my
age so if she's not a Belgian will you
wait for a year for her she's not a
virgin but I wait for a year if I was
yeah I could do I could do it's not
likely are you sleeping with other
people at the time you're waiting yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
I don't know your favorite girl that
you've been on a date with let's just
take her you guys can think of whoever
your favorite ex is whatever all right
would you have waited a year for her
yeah I did oh you did okay uh so you'll
wait a year you'll wait two months two
months you'll wait what
when you say now you're saying favorite
yo
you know what I would wait visually I
would wait but one of the if we are
talking about favorites it didn't last
it didn't take long it was first time no
but how long would you wait for a girl
you liked that's what I'm saying I just
use that as you know giving oh no I
can't answer that question please answer
the question you're here to answer my
questions
be an answer please it doesn't have to
be set I would wait two months yeah two
months okay thank you thank you so much
you're like three weeks roughly a month
a month yeah so one month two months a
year we gotta yeah okay so step one
sleep with her as soon as possible
and way up to are you up to one month
to a year
on the guy because what if you wait a
year and you don't like it um
I wasn't only in that one into that one
song yeah
okay well okay so don't wait now we're
going back don't wait uh I don't know
just just for him though he's waiting
yeah okay so next step okay so when
should you ask her to make you a coffee
that's what we have
okay so what what else how else do you
bat to for a good woman
you know what
the good woman yeah I think you need it
depends on the communication and the
conversation that you have so going
coffee is
I agree apple and the maddest thing is
the girl I'm seeing now this is the
first time I've ever gone coffee and we
had a mad conversation in Costa over
coffee and I've never done that before
which is mad but why is she telling you
well once you have a good comment
through conversation and through certain
things a man would get an idea so like
what adding on to what Rome's the same
with family values traditional maybe
even fear of God like conversations with
her you understand a lot more about it
you know I'm saying if she could can she
even conversate can we have a proper
conversation together you know what I'm
saying
okay so take on coffee date sleep with
her as soon as possible coffee day after
I'll finish waiting
oh oh so that yeah okay I know coffee
day after you finish waiting that's a
waste of time no man you gotta go first
what okay
go on coffee date either before or after
you sleep with her
can I just say really quickly I promise
the reason why you could say that now is
because you're in a position to be open
to be receptive to her as well you know
some guys would be like what you know
like we're going clubbing or you know it
depends on the man as well yeah 100 I'm
not going to blame on the man but it's a
two-way street a lot of pearly's list
Manhattan so I've probably gone through
dating women going through this gone
through that so now when I meet someone
I can analyze a good woman to get what
I'm saying yeah and it's through action
I feel like to your question of where's
all the good women gone yeah I feel like
a lot of good women
don't have the values of back in the day
so women I don't know back in there
because I wasn't born back in the day
but I think a lot of women don't want to
show wife credentials before they're a
wife so they will hold things back
expecting you to put a ring on their
finger
because it's like oh I I can do this but
I'm not going to do these until I'm your
wife
might not thinking right if you're gonna
cool there's other girl out here that's
going to show me what a wife is but
imagine acting like a wife and doing
full for all that cooking's different
but Full Throttle acting like a wife for
you to go and see someone else or play
around but if you don't do that the
man's gone so if you so do you want to
show him do you want to show him that
you are alive because a man coming into
a show when you're ready I'm a husband
what a promotion don't you do the job
that he is at first or do you say
promote me with no work experience
because you know what if I if me okay
one second me and you are in a
relationship or we're building up a
relationship and then we go out
I'm here to protect you but I have to
stand there and just watch you when we
go home now what are you gonna say but
no no one would I mean no no no no you
can't say you know because there's man
out here that's not going to protect you
so our job is to our job
okay forget the semantics my job is to
protect and provide for you if I don't
protect you when I'm out with you and
you're rolling out with me when we go
home what are you saying to me
whatever the situation where you need
protecting and I don't protect you in
that situation what are you doing after
that situation I don't I can't answer
that question because I don't know what
you mean by protective you're deciding
that he's not the one that doesn't mean
it's happened to me before there was
like an accident yeah in Costa Rica
there was like a canoeing thing and a
kayak thing and he didn't show up and I
was I really questioned my future with
this guy that was for me it was done
done it is yeah so if you don't show up
all right he didn't but if you don't
show your wife credentials to the man
what do you think he's gonna do the
thing is there's an extent there's a
limit you can't do everything because
you don't know if that man's serious yet
you don't know what's going on but you
can't do everything and I'm not you're
not out here
but that's
like that's the thing like you're going
into something in bad faith oh I can't
do much too much for him otherwise he
might not pick me up anyway yeah but but
it's like you're going into things in
fear and you don't get anything worth
having if you go into [__] scared
exactly like you can get your heart
broke like it happens scared money don't
make no money yeah but it's like you
have to in order to okay in order to to
start this whole podcast I had to invest
first but women want all the outcomes
without having to invest anything
because I feel like it's a two-way thing
yeah well she just said a husband has to
come to him it's a two-way thing
don't you think Paul it's a two-way
thing so if I'm if I'm it's 50 50 and
then you're right from the same page
that's different
I'm not gonna do the most and you're
doing the least okay so I have a
question do you when you go on date two
pays he does but I will pay I can pay
you know I didn't say you can pay I said
who pays the guy will okay so why does
he have to invest in you before he's
before you slept with that can I tell
you something yes no no no like we have
to think about this why does he have to
invest in you before you've slept with
him but I've done that before to men
I've paid on first dates no I've offered
like you know
I've done I'm talking about what
typically happens you're a pretty girl I
know these I know these men pay for you
I feel like men I feel like men are in
um a stereotypical mindset where they
feel like they're the big they're the
big man they have to be responsible for
paying for first date and stuff like
that so I feel like that's why they do
it automatically
men are more you you're right men are in
more traditional roles than women so
it's like the men are coming to you in a
traditional role they're taking you on a
date they're paying but you're you're
saying I can't be a traditional woman
for him I can't give him wifely duties
when off the bat before he even knows if
he's gonna get sex from you which is
what men want right he's paying
200 pounds uh nothing to you guys so
raise your hand of 200 pounds if the
investment goes right it's great if it
doesn't go right okay okay if one is 200
pounds of nothing so none of these men
are men
of course they're men but there's
different calibers of men okay they're
not they're not the right caliber what's
the caliber yeah what's the caliber
what's that about no but I'm I just know
you don't stand on your words I have a
certain type of man like I like a man
that's you know I wanna I wanna I want a
man that's like a leader in a high
position that that can teach me because
I want to be in that place too so and
you're willing to show with nothing no I
listen like I said 200 pounds ain't
nothing to a man you could show him
everything and he would just and he
could possibly not be serious of you and
be speaking to another girl or sleeping
with someone else and that's the that's
the only reason
no until I know that you're serious I
will give I can get I can surrender to
you you're not even respecting a man's
pocket on the first day like I said 200
pounds is nothing to imagine
no you said 200 pounds ain't nothing to
it man yeah and then when and then when
all of these guys said no that is
something to me you shat on them you
said that you said they're not a high
enough caliber of man but I'm saying
from my experience
um they people have paid and I've been
on dates and I've never spoke to a
person again after and they spent a lot
of money you know what I mean you're not
valuing their time and money because you
think that every single one of them
that's spending that money whether it's
100 pound or 200 pounds you think all of
them have got it there's some man that
probably have taken you out on date and
that's their loss probably but I would
never know exactly so then but you're
still not respecting their money I I
don't think about it like that exactly
because you're so you're still saying
that you you can't give them too much
but they're spending 200 pounds on you
on a first date but I don't think the
way guys go on they act like money is
nothing to them and they and they're you
know what I mean so why would I would be
so conscious like unless I love you and
I know about your financial situation
you'll be completely okay but this is
the thing you're just not appreciative
because you're saying I wanna no you're
not I'm listening to you speak does she
come off appreciative to anyone no no
I'm not an ungrateful person okay but
I'm listening to you speak if I liked a
guy and I spoke to my level and he came
to me and said I can't even afford to
take you out in a certain place I would
not have a problem with that believe me
you just you just said it ain't nothing
to a man I went out there
right but I said when all the guys in
here said no that is something to me you
said they are not the caliber of man you
insult
so I said broke men don't date that's
right okay so a man's broke if he
doesn't want to spend 200 pounds again
I'm from I'm from a one percent like top
earning family my like broke men can
just not want to spend 200 pounds on
someone they don't know they don't have
to yeah but I don't ask for it's not
about that you know what if a man really
likes you and he's into you he would
spend his last 200 pounding without you
knowing I would have known that because
they got that they have money
but it's not like a man's going on like
anything imagine it's not going we're
not going to openly say oh we're going
to the dinner table the bill comes oh
you know I can't afford this [__]
someone I've never been in the situation
yeah you're never gonna be that I've
never been so I can't relate what's your
name royal royal you're never going to
be in that situation where man's gonna
be on the table I've had one guy say to
me that like go for coffee and you know
he's he I think he's I think he was
testing me but I was fine with that
because I actually liked him like it's
not an issue
no he never but he said that you know
I'm not in a great position right now
and I fine because I knew he was
intelligent and I knew that he was
someone I could build with because he's
very smart he just wasn't in the right
place at the time now I didn't have an
issue that unfortunately it didn't work
out why did it work out well he's he's
not funny
it's not about money like I I'm not a
shallow person so please let's not do
that but I know I'm not talking about
we're just repeating back what you're
saying I'm speaking from my own
experience so far I can't say anything
else but there could have been at least
two hours I've never had a man that's
not been able to pay for something that
he I'm aware of and he has I've never
had that you're aware of there could
have been at least one man that took you
on that date that was the last time
probably yeah and I would never have
knew so and I'll and I'm concerned
but I do respect that but I I think if
you think broke men shouldn't date then
should or then should fat women not date
is
I just want to know if we have the same
energy no do you know what it is I feel
like beauty is in the eye of the
beholder so um
the beholder period so there's a guy
that might not
money isn't it money is in the Bible the
beholder
if your mentality is above average and
you're broke I [__] with you because I
know you got potential and that we can
build together we can be powerful but
what is potential it's money later like
that's all it is potentials money later
it's more about their life okay if you
meet Brokey at 25 and you're with him
for five years he's still broke he
unemployed what you're saying say that
again sorry broke you mean a broken guy
25 and he's unemployed and now now um
he's 30. um you're still with him he's
unemployed are you staying or going uh
no because you're not pushing me to my
limit no I wouldn't what five you
wouldn't ride up five years if he is
unemployed and broke for five years and
doesn't want to make a move how long
does it take to create a proper business
and be successful in life if you're
unemployed not doing nothing
like don't worry about it okay I forget
unemployed for five years
I'm with you but
but it's lying yeah you're just lying
because you're like oh if he has the
right mentality I don't care about money
okay but I said like all the ambition
translates to is money later so when
women say oh I don't care about money
yes it does because because women women
do leave if they men don't make enough
money if women outer in the men they
leave the average woman but I feel like
that the average woman will leave but
you are the average woman I mean the
average mindset
okay what makes you different because I
I'm just I feel like I'm very deep and
um I've just learned I've really taken
that time out to study life and to
understand how life is I'm 32 now okay
eight last month so I feel like I've
taken time out from in to go inwards and
to learn about life and to just you know
be more not logical but be more um on
point I don't know how to explain it but
I don't think my mindset's average I
don't think I will ever be average and I
really believe in myself okay you are
100 average you're a comedian no she's a
comedian though no no no look at me look
in the Dead series
and that's not an insult I think I have
an average check I don't think yeah
because I even said before I came on the
show she's she's a badass like she's
built all this you're lying again
didn't I say that to you I've been
talking about that stuff before I met
you but I'm saying like the way you
speak okay and I'm telling you I've met
women with a top 10 20 do you know how
many women I speak to hundreds hundreds
and I'm saying like I've met women with
the top 10 20 mine so I'm not saying
it's horrible but I'm saying an average
chick when it comes to mindset do you
know what I think I just think I think
money's not I didn't I didn't think
money is important so it's nothing to me
but see you've contradicted yourself
like 20 times in this conversation it's
very chaotic to like speak to you like
it's very chaotic because I don't really
understand what you're saying okay
because in one hand you kind of we're
speaking down to the men in the room
because they don't want to spend 200
pounds on a date then you're saying
money is nothing do you see how that's
confused nothing so paying 200 pounds
what is that that I don't that's fine
it's nice because they said I didn't
appreciate it and I do but it's not I
didn't think about it because it's
money's money it just is what it is
because that's what I mean okay okay
I understand yeah okay okay so I
understand what you're saying I just
don't think you understand how it sounds
and it sounds really unappreciated then
it is what it is
I can't change my opinion it is because
you spent 200 pounds every night on
dinner on yourself me I spend a lot of
money not every night no no I can't why
because that's irresponsible
I've had a long-term relationship where
we live together but I've never relied
on a man for anything in my whole entire
life so so it can I cares your question
okay so all right you've you've never
been proposed to not really not like
that no okay okay so if you were if you
had this amazing mindset you're 32 you
do kids no okay so do you know what your
chances below 50 of having a child
possibly but if you're if you're single
at 30 your chance is like 40 of having a
kid so you're more likely to never have
children 30 and at 32 that means you're
three years away from geriatric
pregnancy wow like so that means if
you're single today you got to find a
guy in three years to agree to marry you
um and agree to get in a long-term
relationship marry you and then have a
kid or just get pregnant so so the odd
so physically right right statistically
okay okay okay
so so and based off of like the so the
last you've been dating since what
you're 18 no no well yeah okay so so 10
12 to 14 years you've been unsuccessful
well
right yeah so if you're single right and
I'm not claiming to be the all like I
know everything but I'm saying how how
can you say you're in the top like you
have this amazing mindset if no men have
picked your mindset and it's not looks
you're pretty my mindset changed at 20
at age 28 so before that I was a
different person four years ago okay so
you've got four years to try out this
mindset
and okay I've been going free stuff okay
so and you've been acute you've been
going through things so you've been
accumulating relationship kind of
whatever where you were problematic
my pussy's tight
okay okay is this
you're in the danger zone
can I just say it wouldn't take three
months to come to a decision on this one
and you're so lovely honestly you have
so much going for you I really like you
thank you don't say things like that
keep it for yourself I'm playing around
I don't think you understand okay okay
how is a husband gonna hear that yeah
I'm genuinely trying to help you I'm
trying to help you so seriously so like
those are fake eyelashes yeah do you
know what those stand for do you know
what the history of those are it's
literally what hookers used to use to
keep calm out of their eyes I couldn't I
could probably believe that yeah yeah
sure okay okay okay so and when men see
that they like hoop earrings that signal
yeah yeah that's it and the ears aren't
too bad but but I'm saying when you're
saying like my tight like is that what
you want your wife and the mother of
your kids to see but the thing is I'm
just a funny person like I'm really
outspoken I mean and I know I'm I'm a
focus I like to think I'm funny you know
a comedian but like there's some things
that you really shouldn't say publicly
if you want to be taken seriously from a
guy I think that um
you know if it's meant to be it's meant
to be he's out there somewhere and he'll
appreciate it do you think they're broke
do you think a broke fat guy should say
oh if it's meant to be women will like
me
or do you think he should improve I
personally would definitely improve but
okay yeah okay so if you're if your
mindset is off do you think we say it's
meant if it's meant to be it's meant to
be or do we try to improve always try to
improve so so how do we improve as women
if we can't even admit there's a problem
right and so right now it's like it's
like you're kind of living and delusion
everyone's like you know maybe it's not
a good look and you're like well it's
just how I am but I feel like me saying
my pussy's tight it isn't determine it
isn't determine how many men I've slept
with if I'm a hoe do I go out and suck
dick every week
I wanna hear from them what do you hey
blessing
laughing as a guy you're out to your
more traditional guy you want to be
married right bring me in this one all
right all right what do you what do you
what do you think when a woman says that
canceled okay
[Music]
but the thing is if guys if guys see
signals that you're a hoe they're not
going to investigate to find out they're
just going to think how how like they're
not gonna go and do these deep dot like
no they're just gonna they're just gonna
write you I agree with that but I think
it takes an individual to take time to
actually get to know the person see
they're really like that okay but the
men you want don't have time because
they're working what happened
like where did that go in all of this
conversation wait wait imagine what I'm
sorry where did that where did waiting
for marriage come in this conversation
like where did that go like why did that
leave the world
uh women yeah why because I think women
because well because I think women we're
in control of the like the sex so we're
in control of the Chastity of the sexual
Marketplace I think virgins have a hard
time nowadays because like one
why would a man wait for a woman that's
not a virgin
they wouldn't so and the problem I think
that virgins are going to have is how
does he know she's a virgin with how
much women lie nowadays yeah and how
does he know like even if he he gets a
virgin and this I've spoken to guys with
this like about Virgin I'm not saying
guys don't want it but I think it's more
difficult because of the marketplace
because even if you get a virgin like
she could still go on social media and
leave but I still think it's a valuable
value to have and I think I agree with
somebody to marry them then you should
like just wait simply that's that that's
why they believe do you think that so
what about the women that okay so again
the average woman here
one out of three women has an STD one
out of three women's have an abortion do
you think they should say we're going to
wait till marriage
I mean I think they should stop doing
what they're doing because they're
they're if they keep doing that they are
going to further their likeliness of not
getting a man not being married not
having kids and being miserable no and
it's hard because it's like part of me
agrees with you I think it's idealistic
but I think like telling a single mother
wait till you're married good luck I
mean that's that's a girl that slept
with like 20 dudes good luck stop at
least stop because if you're gonna keep
sleeping with dudes you're gonna when
you're 30 you're gonna be like 100 guys
you know so at least stop now and I
think it comes from Family Values like
how you're raised you didn't raise me
that way I know that's what's so
shocking before when I told my
grandmother I was marrying your dad she
was like well I hope you've slept with
him and I was shocked because she was a
hardcore Christian and her upbringing
was in the church 100 but she's like if
you don't know then you know you could
be getting yourself into trouble yeah I
know I'm not saying that was right but I
was shocked when she said that I just
think like from a guy's point of view
like if a girl's not a virgin like a guy
shouldn't wait I like I think like why
would a guy so I think that's the tough
thing like for those women it's like
well what are they like what you're
gonna because I I think a guy that does
that as a simp to be honest if she's not
a virgin wait you're gonna you're gonna
buy a used car for new prices yeah no
and I'm and I'm in a relationship that's
saying to Mary and we're waiting for
marriage and I think oh that's so cute I
think that's a beautiful thing and I
just want more women to fall into that
role fall into that that place because
it's such a beautiful thing to have with
somebody and to sleep with 20 guys and
50 guys and say like my is tight like
that's not cute like but it's not what
do you think what do you think of the
women that say you're missing out like
you just need to see what's out there
missing out on what getting drunk and
like having with a bunch of guys and
like like my body's a temple like my
body is precious anything that goes on
it or in it is very like it has to be
pure I believe in Purity and if it's not
pure it's not right I agree so you don't
mind so your mind's a virgin right now
I'm not gonna say like but that's like
very personal
basically I've just I was talking bro
about this conversation so obviously
that's my answer
the pure thing yes you can't be pure and
my partner are pure well both virgins in
because what's the definition of pure
Clarity just give Clarity
that means nothing has touched your body
your body
is pure that means nobody can touch you
none of YouTube I'm not gonna expose his
life